why is this dude able to do what he does
right what's the secret sauce and that's
you know the answer I came to and this
is partially his own words is that
um he he Reasons from first principles
he likes that term and once I started to
understand you know what does that
really mean
um and you know it's one it's one of the
two major ways to reason you know
reasoning from first principles it's a
physics term it means you you just you
you ignore all the noise you ignore all
the conventional wisdom and the
assumptions and your own previous dogma
and everything else and you just look at
the facts you look at you know how much
the parts of the rocket weigh and the
force of gravity uh and the wind
resistance and you use that to say Can a
lock a rocket be landed can you can you
launch a rocket and then land it
and his answer to that question was yes
so he did it now there's a whole other
kind of reasoning reasoning by analogy
which is when instead of kind of
reasoning from first principles is
creating uh conclusion from scratch
based on first principles core kind of
axioms and and facts
reasonably by analogy is taking one of
the many existing conclusions or dogmas
out there and basically photocopying it
into your own head as what you believe
is true so these to use the rocket
example again what most people like Elon
would have done in that situation is say
if you could land a rocket the Soviet
Union and NASA would have done it a long
time ago they have every reason to do it
it saves a ton of money they had the
budgets they had the scientists I coming
out of this and there's no way I must be
missing something people do this with
companies I I have this good idea for a
company but if it was such a good idea
someone else would have done it there's
you can name any major part of life
politics uh you know scientific you know
beliefs um beliefs about the the world
or you know you know about the business
World about whatever
all of it is um or art you know what's
what makes a good art about it all of
that is almost always there's just this
big kind of tapestry of conventional
wisdom and most of us just say that's
reality and so if my independent
reasoning disagrees with the tapestry
conventional wisdom I must be wrong I
must be missing something
and that
is a humble normal way to think if
you're in 30 000 BC or you know 10 000
BC when when generation after generation
after generation things didn't change
very much so conventional wisdom was
wise it was the accumulation of a lot of
trial and error about the same repeated
kind of life and so you were stupid you
were naive if you thought you were
smarter than that but now when the world
changes so quickly and Technology
changes in every five years the new
possibilities that are different than
the old ones conventional wisdom is
actually very it lags behind it's very
foolish it's wrong
um and so it's so it's not often anymore
it's not always wrong and so it's
actually very rational to say I'm going
to trust my own reasoning when it
disagrees with conventional wisdom but
it were so wired not to do that so most
people they say I'm not going to build
the rocket because there's no way I'm
right NASA is wrong Elon doesn't think
that way to me his secret sauce is that
he is
um extremely good it just he just has
that he doesn't have this this
irrational thing that overrides his own
reasoning
um uh he's able to say I guess
I guess everyone's wrong I guess NASA I
guess NASA didn't do it right uh and
that just separates him right there I
mean you know there's a lot of things
that he's good at but that right there
makes him very unusual and so again with
Twitter
someone who Reasons from first
principles they're going to experiment a
lot they're going to get something stuff
right they're going to get some stuff
wrong but they're going to create change
you know Steve Jobs with the iPhone and
use that example too like
that you know they didn't just say well
what should our keyboard look like
because that's conventional wisdom that
there had to be a keyboard they just
said what should a mobile device be and
really reason from first principles and
came up with something totally different
and then turned out to disrupt the
entire industry so real disruption
whether it's artistic or entrepreneurial
or technological uh or intellectual it's
usually there's some real original
thinking going on from someone who has
the kind of that Epiphany that my
original reasoning is as good as
anything else out there
um and that and that I'm just as good as
a person to figure this out as as anyone
and it's but there's always a fine line
isn't there Tim between bravery and
recklessness and a lot of the time it's
if your idea works so if your idea Works
everyone goes yeah he was Brave what a
brave dude but if it doesn't work it's
like do you see what I mean so it's it's
a superpower and at the same time it can
be your greatest weakness
definitely it's a riskier way to live in
general but um another thing that Elon
points out is that
um a lot of times people are more afraid
than they should be they think you know
I I drew this in my post as a scale of
danger from one to ten and I said that
just say seven to ten is actually
dangerous you know either physically
dangerous or you're truly going to have
to you know not be able to feed your
kids or something
and then everything one to seven is you
know increasing risk but it's not
nothing that bad is going to happen if
it goes wrong and that I think that we
all hang on the one to three Zone
or you know maybe one to four Zone and
we think four five six and seven that
area is super dangerous and so we don't
do it
and the people that realize the danger
doesn't start till seven huge superpower
because they can go play in the five six
you know four five six seven areas and
change the world and do stuff and and
and they might fail and that what
they've realized is that it doesn't
really matter failure is okay uh Elon
has a quote about like
um
he says I don't know I don't know why
more people don't start a company what's
the worst that happens you're not gonna
starve you're not going to die of
exposure right like what's the worst
that's gonna happen if the company
doesn't work out
um and that that not you know thinking
like that would make a lot more people
start companies
um and so many people sit there and they
dream about their company their whole
life they dream about writing that album
their whole life or whatever it is
writing that book and they never do it
because they they think that it is
their brain is incorrectly assessed that
as as real risk to fail at that maybe
it's a little bit of embarrassment and
the truth is most people are
self-absorbed not even thinking about
you it's a dumb reason not to do
something so again I can say this but I
feel it too we all have this kind of
irrational fear of of failure um and so
yes you can be more Reckless and I think
if you someone who's so reckless they go
up to the eight nine ten
um that's too far I mean maybe not for
everyone but like you have one life like
I don't think you should actually risk
your life very often I don't think you
should risk completely destroying your
financial situation you know to the
point where you you're again you have a
family and they can't go to school
anymore whatever it is
um I I think that that Reckless though a
lot of people call that four to seven
area Reckless when they see it and that
I think is wrong I think that's good
recklessness these people should get up
there and not worry about failing in
that area